you know the thing I love about the
Emmys is that we get to see so many TV
stars in one place has it hit you yet
you're hosting the Emmys no I was with
first-timers Colin Jost and Michael che
SNL's up for 21 awards but will any
viewers be more fixated on all their
romances who are you bringing with you
oh yeah who are you bringing will figure
it out you know from Colin and his girl
Scarlett Johansson to Pete Davidson and
his seatmate fiancee Ariana Grande and
with nominees like Leslie Jones
presenters including Alec Baldwin Kate
McKinnon and Tina Fey SNL will be
everywhere and look out for these
lovebirds Justin Timberlake will be
beside wife Jessica Biel who's up for
the sinner this is us nominee sterling K
Brown will be with white Ryan and his
co-stars it's an opportunity to spend
time with my cast who I love and adore
although interestingly enough get this
can I break this no I can't break that
no he wouldn't confirm anything but
don't be surprised if Sterling's also
involved in Monday's big show here's
what we can confirm the Governor's Ball
after party will be on point let's break
down the menu by the numbers 3,000
pounds of prime beef about 2,500 pounds
of an olive oil poached salmon over 32
pounds of summer truffles that came
imported from Italy and to wash it all
down 7,000 cocktails lots to celebrate
with from vodka to bubbly 5,000 bottles
enough to keep everybody with a smile on
their face
you
[Music]
[Applause]